bonjour et merci d'être heureux en
direct avec nous sur ert france alors
tout d'abord quelle est votre réaction
concernant cette déclaration l'afrique
qui devra patienter jusqu'au deuxième
semestre pour accéder au vaccin anti
coded
ce n'est pas très surprenant quand on
voit la situation sa libération au
continent africain c'est vrai que c'est
moins touchés mais les prévisions début
de pandémie donner l'impression que le
la fiq avait payé un lourd tribut à
cette pandémie
il est heureux de constater que
l'afrique n'a pas été autant pour celle
que certains le prédisaient et s'il
n'est pas temps touché peut-être que
cela peut justifier le fait aujourd'hui
ce ne soit pas vers elle que l'on
d'orienter les priorités l'accès au
vaccin mais dans le même temps ce qui
peut être déprimant concernant cette
annonce c'est que l'afrique reste
aujourd'hui malgré tous les efforts qui
sont faits sur le plan international
reste quand même la dernière roue du
carrosse
quand il s'agit de s'occuper de la santé
publique des urgences diplomatiques il
ya cette réforme de par exemple pour
prendre de quelques cas précis des
dernières années et à cette réforme des
institutions internationales qui est
demandé par l'afrique et qui n'est pas
obtenue il ya la question de la place au
conseil de sécurité qui n'est toujours
pas obtenu est donc l'affairé reste
toujours dû malheureusement plus une
variable d'ajustement sur la scène
internationale comme acteur à part
entière alors l'afrique qui est
confrontée à de nombreux défis
on l'a dire le continent africain et et
re est relativement épargnée par cette
pandémie
contrairement à l'europe comment est-ce
que vous expliquer ces chiffres qui sont
assez bas est ce que voilà il ya un
problème de recensement des malades sur
place je pense qu'il ya un souci tout
d'abord dans les statistiques
je ne le dirai pas que les gens
surestiment sous-estiment le niveau de
la pandémie sur le continent africain
il faudrait que les gens à experts
directe-- et que les détections ne
soient pas des détections anonyme que
l'on identifie très clairement les gens
d'argent
si par exemple elles ont fait 3 fois ou
quatre fois les tests une s'agit pas de
cas qu aucun e distincts mais de quatre
cas de la même personne et s'est fait
tester plusieurs fois ça déjà c'est le
premier c'est le premier volet parce que
la détection est très important dans un
deuxième temps quand on en a fini avec
la détection il faut aussi qu'on ait la
capacité de centraliser de sécuriser ses
résultats et dans les deux cas de figure
je pense que d'abord le problème de la
confiance
les gens ne vont pas toujours se faire
détecter et puis un deuxième cas qui est
que souvent les tests coûte beaucoup
trop cher pour les patients et donc ils
restent chez eux ils vont pas se faire
tester et dans ces conditions là je ne
suis pas certain que les statistiques
disent toute la vérité
une chose est certaine c'est que
l'afrique aujourd'hui et heureusement
épargnés par la pandémie
mais ce n'est pas par rapport aux
statistiques que l'on peut le dire c'est
par rapport à la vie des gens au
quotidien que l'on pense tu attires pas
tant de cas 2,2 qu'ovide que cela mais
que l'économie en est quand même assez
assez d'ébranler et ce n'est pas rien
non plus une défiance vis-à-vis des
tests est-ce que vous pensez que les
africains seront également voilà
réticents face aux campagnes de
vaccination que pourrait lancer
plusieurs pays africains
il y est sont réticents et je crois
qu'ils n'ont pas tort de l'ex la
pandémie de kobe 19 n'est pas la
première pandémie dans l'affectif chimie
a vu avant cela des bolets le sida cela
fait des années que la fiq est victime
de ces deux pandémies
cela fait plus de trente ans aujourd'hui
et l'on n'a toujours pas trouvé de
vaccins pour prévenir contre ces points
début de la pandémie de politis 9
s'imaginant que c'est quand même la
pandémie tueur à tout le monde
imaginons que
soit peut-être une inspiration spéciale
qu'ils soient qui permet aux
scientifiques de la crouée mais en 90
c'est quand même beaucoup trop rapide
pour que l'on se dise que toutes les
étapes ont été franchies vert vers
l'obtention de ce verset vers
l'obtention de ce médecin faisant
confiance aux scientifiques mais je
pense qu'il ne faudrait pas qu'on plus
étonnant est éteint dans le commercial
c'est un enjeu également de sécurité
sanitaire pour les pays du nord puisque
pour les pays du sud et donc dans le sud
si la pandémie ne fait pas tout
et si les gens restent omnisciente a la
poisse qui a été proposée notamment par
conditions de stockage
parce que l'autre enjeu au delà
d'obtenir le vaccin c'est de le stocker
dans des conditions convenables
nous sommes dans les pays sur le
continent africain où la chaleur est
très élevé où les conditions de stockage
ne sont pas toujours facile il faudrait
peut être réfléchir à trouver un vaccin
au niveau africain ou tropicalisé il
permettrait au pays d'avoir la capacité
de stocker sans que ce soit un problème
d'utiliser des vaccins frelaté et que de
l'autre côté cela garantissent tout des
conditions de sécurité pour le stockage
et l'utilisation sur les panneaux oui
comme ayo dernière question vous
connaissez bien l'afrique vous en êtes
un spécialiste à votre avis dans quel
pays
la vaccination sera tu es la plus
difficile à mettre en place
je suis le faire le pronostic de savoir
si certains faits sont les accueillant
par rapport à ce vaccin que d'autres
mais je pense que de façon générale les
africains ne sont pas réticents au
vaccin
quand vous prenez le tétanos ou prenez
la tuberculose vous prenez toutes les
les maladies qui parfois sévit sur ce
continent
les gens ne sont pas réticents au vaccin
ils sont réticents quand tu crois qu'on
a afin de les piéger par rapport au
vaccin
il ya eu des séquences de vaccination
anarchique de tests de batley avaient
retenu que sur le continent africain qui
ont fait de gros dégâts
les gens ne font plus confiance à
l'industrie pharmaceutique par rapport à
cela
donc je la dois être très encadrée pour
que de part et d'autre sur le continent
n'est pas cette méfiance là qui peut
être néfaste également dans la lutte
contre la pandémie parce que c'est
d'abord un problème de confiance est pas
qu hollande
pas être vaccinés c'est qu'ils avaient
beaucoup de dérives et prendre ses des
riffs l'air et à une existence qui est
né ce n'est pas toujours ce n est
malheureusement n'aurait lutte contre
les différentes maladies qui s'abattent
sur le continent africain
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président du club de l'information
africaine